is there such a thing as writer's block
there are some writers who don't have
writer's block and there are some
writers who definitely do have writer's
block in my experience the solution the
cure for writer's block is to write
about the writer's block because you
need to dissolve it writing can be like
a corrosive acid if you're tense and you
just don't know why and you're just in a
bad mood and you're just angry if you
write about that feeling what does it
feel like it feels like chopping at
something made out of ice it just feels
very much like you will eventually get
to why you're angry you'll dissolve the
feelings you'll corrode the sort of
feelings around that anger and get to
the reason why so with writer's block if
you write about the writer's block
you'll understand what it's about I
think it you know for some writers it's
it's like a symptom of your truest
instincts your very best nature trying
to course-correct you you know trying to
tell you you really don't want to go
that way it's trying to sort of say wait
something isn't right about what we're
doing here it's you're you're sort of
creative unconscious or subconscious way
of saying to you stop stop stop
there's a reason why there's a block
it's just like a roadblock
the road is blocked for a reason it's
you know usually not just arbitrarily
blocked a road is not usually blocked
because someone decided you know what I
think I'm gonna block this road today so
you've got to kind of trust that that
same basic sort of logic is incorporated
within the cells of our own body and
we're probably not going to experience
writer's block unless some better part
of us some more know
aspect of us knows the bridge is out up
ahead that road goes the wrong way you
know so right about the writer's block
and figure out why you're blocked
I was blocked on my last two books
because I'm trying to write these two
novels I write one I don't like it I
write another one it did not work and I
thought well I can't write anymore
I can't write I would sit down to write
and I would be for the first time in my
life confronted with just blankness and
then I would write something and it
would be just bad not know depth and it
was because I had decided what I was
going to write next I had already
decided what I was going to write next
but inside the deepest part of me it
wanted to write something else so there
was sort of this like digging in of the
heels you know where it was like no I
don't want to write a novel right now
you've said you know it's almost like
I'm gonna write a novel because I
promised my publisher I would write a
novel not a good enough reason you know
not really what's important is you gotta
write something great you got to write
something that has to be written you've
got to write something that you can't
stop so writer's block you know it's
like that's it's something that I think
is it's like it's like physical pain
it's your body telling you pay attention
to this area there might be something
you need to look at here the the the
worst thing to do with writer's block is
is kind of like the worst thing to do
with back pain you know if you have back
pain you don't want to stay in bed for
the next five years you need to stretch
you know you need to begin physical
therapy you need to maybe do yoga or
pilates you need to move with writer's
block you don't stay away from the
writing don't
put the writing aside and think well
I'll wait until the writer's block goes
away or I'll wait until the solution
comes to me because that's not how it
works for a writer the solution comes to
us as we're writing it comes
mid-sentence so for a writer the answer
the solution to writer's block is to
write about the writer's block why do
you have it why are you not writing why
does it suck really why why do you think
it should be what should it be how
should it be different when I think
about writing what is it that I feel do
I feel angry do I feel afraid do I feel
like I'm going to be judged you know it
could be a case of you knows you're off
plot or off point it could be that
there's something deeper the better
truer juicier that you really need to
write about that maybe you're too
embarrassed to write maybe you're too
afraid to write they're too
self-conscious to write all things you
need to listen to all erasers of
writer's block